louisville au kentucky
il est environ 8h30 le matin
nous sommes devant la dernière clinique
d'avortement de l'état encore ouverte
il y en avait huit en 1996 ici les
prouve il mène une guerre sans relâche
contre le droit à l'avortement
ils manifestent tous les jours
devant cette clinique ils sont équipés
d' affiches de mégaphones de chapelets
et puis sans cesse il essaie de
convaincre des femmes de ne pas attenter
à la vie du style de leur foetus des
bénévoles pro-choix vêtus de leurs
dossards orange en dur sans brancher les
invectives des pro vie de leur côté ils
tentent de protéger la clinique et
surtout les patients
je
apeurée et vulnérables ces femmes sont
escortés jusqu'à l'intérieur où elles
ont rendez vous avec un médecin
l'atmosphère est tendue
on leur crée à pleins poumons qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit de tuer leur bébé le
kanak et baby amène au kentucky fait
partie d'une douzaine d'états qui mène
une charge à fond de train contre le
droit à l'avortement ici
la plus récente loi interdit toute
interruption de grossesse après
seulement six semaines
l'alabama lui est allé jusqu à
criminaliser l'acte même dans le cas de
viol et d'inceste
c'est absurde dit un building de
l'organisation et si l ue qui défend les
cliniques visé devant les tribunaux le
but ultime des républicains selon elle
forcer la cour suprême a renversé sa
décision de 1973 qui a légalisé
l'avortement
partout aux états unis des
manifestations s'organisent pour
préserver un acquis durement gagnés au
kentucky
des femmes et des hommes dénonce ce
qu'il qualifie d' intimidation à la
clinique de louisville
laura et grijalva patrouilles aux abords
de cette clinique d'avortement
depuis des années cette mère de sept
enfants affirme au contraire employé la
méthode douce pour dit elle
aider les femmes et sauver des vies
laura tente de les amener dans la
clinique pro vie à côté pour y subir une
échographie
c'est ce qu'elle a fait en décembre 2016
pour convaincre chelsea de garder son
bébé voir son futur enfant dans son
ventre dit elle a tout changé dit
n'avoir jamais regretté de ne pas s'être
fait avorter il d'abord eu confiance en
laura laura est catégorique l'avortement
ne devrait pas être un choix pour les
femmes pour un accroc means 34 ans
l'avortement dans son cas était
incontournable
elle a été rompu deux grossesses parce
que nous dit elle elle était pauvre et
ne voulait pas être une mère anna n'a
pas honte de s'être fait avorter le
droit selon elle de contrôler sa vie et
son corps est fondamental pour les
américaines
la guerre que se livrent pro choix et
pro vie ne se terminera probablement
jamais les deux camps sont
irréconciliables que la cour suprême
renverse éventuellement ou non le
jugement de 1973 la lutte pour le droit
à l'avortement continuera de diviser la
société américain
[Musique]